deutschland beteiligt sich an den tests
für einen ebola impfstoff und alle
meldungen zum thema rosetta denn das
thema beherrschte den klicks und block
jetzt in den krieg zum top 5 news
deutschland testet ebola impfstoff in
deutschland laufen die ersten tests für
einen möglichen impfstoff an 30
freiwillige studienteilnehmer erhalten
in den kommenden wochen nahmen
universitätsklinikum hamburg eppendorf
einen wirkstoff namens rv svc buff ziel
dieses ersten versuchs ist es
herauszufinden wie sich der wirkstoff im
körper verhält und wie er aufgenommen
wird
für die teilnehmer der studie besteht
kein infektionsrisiko mit dem tödlichen
erreger die in hamburg durchgeführte
test reihe dauert rund sechs monate und
ist teil eines groß angelegten
internationalen programms in dem zwei
vielversprechende impfstoffe gegen ebola
geprüft werden
die ersten ergebnisse zu dem wirkstoff
sollen bis anfang kommenden jahres
vorliegen sollte der gewünschte schutz
vor dem aggressiven erreger erreicht
worden seien könne die massenproduktion
beginnen
in der studie wird geprüft ob die
studienteilnehmer ausreichend antikörper
gegen den ebola erreger bilden der
wirkstoff aus v10 ist zuvor erfolgreich
an affen getestet worden wie die wirkung
auf den menschen aussieht ist noch
unklar
landung gelungen sonde tod von ihr
schaltet sich ab die wissenschaftler
erhoffen sich mehr über die
zusammensetzung von kometen
herauszufinden und die entstehung
unseres sonnensystems zu entschlüsseln
denn mit der untersuchung des kometen
werfen wir einen blick 4,6 milliarden
jahre zurück in die zeit der entstehung
unseres sonnensystems damals bildete
sich das sonnensystem aus einer
gigantischen staubwolke am mittwoch um
17.04 kam die erlösende nachricht denn
viele länder ist auf dem kometen 67 pico
rivera simek gelandet allerdings gab es
gleich mehrere probleme die ab und sind
nicht abgefeuert worden der kommunen hat
nämlich so gut wie keine anziehungskraft
war damit rund dreieinhalb kilometern
durchmesser viel zu kleines deshalb muss
der länder mit harpunen verankert werden
vormittags war bekannt geworden dass die
kalt gas diese die den fehler länder auf
den kometen drücken sollte sich nicht
einschalten liest dennoch war die
landung auf dem kometen ein erfolg die
ersten bilder welche die erde erreichen
wurden aus drei kilometer bzw aus 40
metern über dem boden aufgenommen
sehr interessant ist auch dass der
rosetta länder für je geräusche
aufzeichnen konnte die vom kometen ins
all geschickt wurden mittlerweile hat
man auch den ursprung dieser geräusche
ausmachen können ein strom elektrisch
geladener partikel erzeuge das klicken
das sich übrigens so anhört einen tag
nach der landung also vergangen
donnerstag gab die europäische
weltraumorganisation esa dann bekannt
dass der viele länder nun mit zwei
beinen auf der kometenoberfläche steht
grund dafür ist dass viele zweimal meer
gelandet ist als geplant durch die
fehlende verankerung hüpfte die
landeeinheit ja quasi hoch und kilometer
und gelangte so zu einem anderen
landeplatz der auch schon vorher als
angepeilte landesstelle diskutiert wurde
und genau das wird viele jetzt zum
verhängnis ihn ist der strom ausgegangen
da seine batterie nicht mit hilfe der
sonnenenergie aufladen konnte denn durch
dieses hüpfen ist der unter einem felsen
gesprungen der ihm das licht nimmt vor
ist befindet sich der kühlschrank große
länder nun im standby modus
die wissenschaftler hoffen dass mit
geringerer entfernung zur sonne eine
aufladung wieder möglich ist aber ist
das überhaupt notwendig laut esa konnten
alle geplanten versuche aktiviert werden
auch die daten der bohrungen konnten zum
schluss noch übermittelt werden also zum
schluss hatte er sich noch in den
kometen geburt ein fakt am rande matthew
taylor projektwissenschaftler für die
esa ist am tag der landung auf skurrile
art und weise aufgefallen durch sein
hemd mit pin up girls wurde er via
twitter zum kurzfristigen star und löste
einen shitstorm aus für diesen auftritt
entschuldigte er sich öffentlich unter
tränen
was genau am tag der landung passiert
ist erfahrt ihr in diesem video der
frösche zum mission rosetta täglich news
rund um raumfahrt um wissenschaft gibt
es in der app und dem blog dafür hier
klicken
alle links wie immer auch in der video
beschreibung was meint ihr wird es den
forschern gelungen viele zu reaktivieren
oder ist das gar nicht nötig diskutiert
es mit mir in den kommentaren ansonsten
bis dann bleibt kann